et le Golden Globe est décerné à kan
[Applaudissements]
Murphy c'est la deè nomination et la
première victoire pour Mury qui gag
golden pour le rôle
deerheimer
[Applaudissements]
openheimer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la V tout d'abord est-ce que j'ai du
rouge à lèvres sur le bout du nez bon je
vais le
[Musique]
laisser je savais la première fois que
je suis arrivé sur un plateau de
Christopher no cétait diff pouvez le
voir au niveau de rigueur de
concentration
d'engagement le manque total de siège
pour les
acteurs je voyais que j'étais entre les
mains d'un réalisateur visionnaire un
maître merci Chris merci Emma pour avoir
eu foi en moi depuis 20 ans et si
de film donc merci
infiniment l'une des choses les plus
magnifiques et vulnérables quand on est
acteur c'est que pas vraiment s'en
sortir tout seul et donc on a
vraiment un ensemble d'acteurs ily blun
Rober jor maton g merci de m'avoir porté
à bout de bras pendant tout ce film
merci
merci merci à Donal Lang et tout le
monde chez Universal d'avoir cru en ce
film dès le début et tous les autres
conomés que vous soyez irlandais ou pas
vous êtes tous des légendes vous avez
fait des créé des œuvres incroyables à
tout mes attachés de presse mon équipe
ma famille j'ai je suis l'homme le plus
chanceux du monde je vous adore
merci